- [Voiceover] Compare
98,989
and 98,899.
So we want to compare these two numbers
and to do that, let's first
think about what these
digits mean.
What do these numbers actually mean?
Looking first at our number on the left,
we have a 9 all the way to the right,
or in the ones place value,
which means just that.
It means nine ones.
Beside that, we have an
8 in the 10s place value,
so that's eight 10s or 80.
This number, these two right here, 89
is the same as an 80 plus a 9.
Beside the 8, we have a 9
in the 100s place value,
so again, we can look at that, 989
is the same as a 900 plus an 80 plus a 9
and let's keep going and
fill in these last two.
We have an 8 in the 1,000s place,
and finally, a 9 in the 10,000s place,
which means nine 10,000s or 90,000,
so 98,989 is the same as
90,000 plus 8,000 plus 900 plus 80 plus 9.
Which of these place values
now seems like the most
important one if we're
deciding how big a number is?
Which one of these has the
biggest impact on the size
of our number?
And the answer is the one
all the way to the left,
whatever place value
is farthest to the left
is the greatest place value,
so it is the most important
in deciding how big
or how small a number is.
So when we compare these
numbers, we're going to start
by comparing the largest place value that
either of them has.
In this case, 10,000s is
the largest place value
both of them has,
and in both cases, it's a 9,
so both of these numbers
start with 90,000
which is equal,
we can't tell yet which one is greater,
so we're going to move to
the next biggest place value.
The next largest place value is the 1,000s
and again, we can see in both cases,
we have an 8 or 8,000,
so looking at what we've
compared so far, these numbers
are identical,
neither is larger than the other,
so we're going to keep going
and again, we're going to pick
the next largest place value,
which is the 100s
and our first number on the
left, we have nine 100s,
nine 100s,
but on the right, we have
eight 100s,
so eight 100s is less than nine 100s,
so this number on the right is less
than our first number,
the number on the left,
or we could say, the
900 is greater than 800
so the number on the left is greater
and this is our greater
than symbol because we want
the open side to be
facing the larger number.
We want the open side
So we'd read this as
98,989 is greater
than 98,899.
And you might be thinking,
but wait, we didn't look
at the 10s and look at the 10s.
Here, we have eight 10s,
but on the right we have nine 10s.
Well, nine 10s is definitely
greater than eight 10s
but it doesn't make up
for having less 100s.
100s are far bigger, 10 times bigger,
than 10s, so they matter more,
they had a bigger impact
on which of these numbers
was larger.
So, we compare until we find
the greatest place value
that's different
and then whichever of those
has the greater number
in that place value is the greater number.
Let's try one more.
So here we're comparing 53,000
and 350,000.
At a quick glance, you might be thinking,
okay, first number 5, first number 3.
The highest place value is bigger here,
it's a 5.
But that's not quite enough.
We still have to be
sure we're comparing the
same place values.
This largest place value here,
this 5,
is in the 10,000s place.
But the largest place
value over here, the 3,
is in the 100,000s place.
So we are actually comparing 300,000
to 50,000.
Those are two different place values.
We want to compare 100,000s to 100,000s,
so looking over here,
how many 100,000s did this number have?
And the answer is a great, big zero.
It has zero 100,000s,
so we can say zero 100,000s
and when we compare that to 300,000,
that's far less.
No 100,000s is much less
than three 100,000s,
so actually, this second number is larger,
so be careful not just to
compare the first number
but the largest place value,
and if there's no digit
in that place value,
we can fill in a zero and then compare.
So to read this, we'll say 53,000
is less,
less,
than 350,000,
and this symbol is less
than because the larger side
is open to the bigger number
and the bigger number
is the second number,
so 53,000 is less than 350,000.